oh my goodness ladies and gentlemen it
is time the final battle
harry versus the dementors
wait hermione what are you what are you
doing hermione
where are you going what is this
where am i supposed to take him people
of the internet's welcome back to harry
potter and the prisoner of azkaban we
are getting
very close to the end game now guys if
you go and look at our tasks here
our next task on the list is visit
hagrid at his hut
in the grounds which as you all know if
you've read the book that is the point
where we are trying to save buckbeak and
at that point i mean that's when things
really start to get crazy we start
traveling back in time i cannot remember
how the game handles all of that but i
know there are only a few things left
and before we get too far into today's
video i want to give a shout out to
another harry potter video game this
harry potter hogwarts mystery and i want
to say thank you to gm city who is very
kindly sponsoring today's video in harry
potter hogwarts mystery you can
customize your own character choose your
house and live out magical moments as a
student at hogwarts i'm actually hosting
my own sweepstakes as well where i'll be
giving away a 25 amazon gift card so
stay tuned to the end to find out how to
win now in harry potter hogwarts mystery
you actually have quite a bit of freedom
to create a custom character that feels
like you with a wide range of diverse
hairstyles and outfits to unlock you can
even decorate and customize your own
dorm room oh and did i mention there's
also quidditch play any time as you
unlock and learn each position work your
way up to captain and progress in an
exciting unique storyline you can also
master new spells and potions to use in
classes for dueling other students and
to progress through the story there's
also a large diverse cast of original
characters to meet become friends or
rivals with and even date now my
favorite house of course is gryffindor
i've always felt such a strong
connection to harry ron hermione the
whole gang and the bravery this house
represents and in this game it's super
fun because you get to interact with
professor mcgonagall as your head of
house now because of the time period
that hogwarts mystery is set my favorite
characters from the movies are here like
dumbledore mcgonagall snape hagrid
weasley twins dobby and all my favorite
magical creatures from the fantastic
beasts films you can download harry
potter hogwarts mystery for free right
now on your mobile device or tablet
using my link in the video description
below in fact if at least 200 of you
download the game using my link i'll
give away a second 25 amazon gift card
to another random entry all you have to
do is download harry potter hogwarts
mystery using my affiliate link in the
description below then screenshot your
character getting sorted and to let me
know which house you get tag me over on
twitter at retrorecontour and i'll be
selecting a random person from those who
reach out and tag me to receive a 25
amazon gift card now if we manage to hit
200 downloads i'll give away an
additional 25 gift card to another
random entry now also full disclaimer
here the link below acts as a creator
code so while harry potter hogwarts
mystery is free to play if you do spend
anything in game that will actually help
support me and the channel once again
thanks to jam city for sponsoring
today's video learned a lot from reading
the comments thank you guys reminding me
to make sure that i use ron just opened
this right here with him and got the
treasure so completely forgot about that
until i started reading more of your
comments so very much appreciated also
learned that fred and george will sell
different items to you
based on which character you are
honestly completely blew my mind
completely blew my mind i had no idea
that it would actually change based on
which character you were
i mean i
i i just never thought to try it so
we'll make sure to stop back by there
and see if we can get anything but first
we mustn't be seen oh i was about to say
we still have the trolls here
so that's something i also learned since
the last episode i learned that the
trolls in fact are
canon in terms of
they did actually use them in hogwarts
for security it wasn't just in book one
and i completely forgot about that
shout out to uh wario land gold pyramid
in the uh comment section who pointed
that out because i totally forgot about
that
totally forgot about that happening in
the books
but they pointed out the exact exact
wording so i went back and was like oh
my goodness completely forgot about that
all right so now let's see i think i
have what do i have two or three
dung bombs let's see okay i have three
and i think we have two trolls to get
past maybe more around the corner unless
they've
uh changed it up a bit
so
let's see man i'm gonna have to get him
out of the way first
oh this is tough i'm really not sure
because if i put it here to the right
okay so let me think this through if i
put it here to the right he's gonna come
over here and investigate
then if i go around this way
and kind of put it here oh that is
not what i meant to do
i just wanted to barely peek out come on
now all right at least i didn't waste
any of my oh no i'm not i don't need to
go back in there at least we did not
waste any of our dung bombs right there
all right we're gonna hop right back out
here
and what i was trying to say is i just i
just barely want to
kind of
poke my way out here and see if i can
alright so
i don't think that's going to give me
enough time
because then this one i would need to
place sort of over on the left like up
against the wall
get that one right there to pursue that
and then go in behind him but as soon as
i start trying to go behind him
i wonder if there's a way to get both of
them after the same dung bomb
okay he's going after that one
wait what no way dude i'm completely
behind that bookshelf at that point
oh my goodness
no way that's super annoying all right
well maybe i was overthinking it let's
try to just put it
nearest this one right here i better
search them again though make sure
because i'm pretty sure yeah it takes
them away
so i'm uh at two now let's see that's
gonna give me three
go ahead and search come on give me four
ah
all right birdie bop bean
okay so let's put you right here
all right so go investigate that
and then put you right here
go investigate that and turn the corner
let's go dude all right all right all
right
now i think there's another one over
here there is
okay
all right so i think i'm good for that
section i hope so
i'm just going to drop it right here i
think
yeah
like i do not even want to mess with
them
but there's more back here isn't there
yep
oh come on get around there get around
there dude no
oh geez
how many are over here i really hope
it's just the one
because i think i only have one dung
bomb
left
oh that is just so creepy how the bloody
baron's just chilling up there
what is he looking ron what are you
what are you looking at
i don't like the way he's looking up
like that like i'm i should be noticing
something up there
okay whatever dude whatever all right
here we go
try to get a little bit closer to him
oh no i'm already out
i have no more
oh that's not good
that's not good
i don't know if this is gonna work guys
i really don't
oh come
dude i'm so i was being so quiet
it must be strictly a proximity thing
because i barely move although i didn't
do the little crouch down like this
maybe i needed to do this i was just
going like this like barely touching the
analog stick
oh my goodness all right so we used up
all our dung bombs so we're gonna have
to get it fresh
apply search here
good thing it gives them to you pretty
consistently
we need at least three
actually no we really need four to be
honest with you
can i search like the same area again
no
and then this one's not going to give me
another one is it
i knew it
all right i can't search that one
without him getting upset
all right so i think let's see this is
what we did right we threw one right
here
and we run around this way
throw one right here get you to go after
that one
make a hard right turn
okay search search search come on
i have no idea what he got okay good
dung bomb
no
are you serious right now
this is ridiculous
this is totally ridiculous
oh am i forgetting is there an easier
way do i have to go this route i won't
make any noise okay
i think i do i think this is the only
way
on the bright side though hopefully
we'll be able to get
oh no is it not gonna oh it's not gonna
give me any more dung bombs come on
oh that just brings okay i got four
though that's good that's good all right
because now we're gonna do this right
here
and then we're gonna toss you right here
i'm just gonna like run through
toss another one right there
all right now he's after it he doesn't
even care about me
come on keep going ron
toss another one right there there you
go you're investigating him
is that it
oh thank goodness
okay
all right but while we're at it let's go
ahead and search
i need to grab a few more dung bombs
yeah i don't think that one comes near
me so i should be able to search this
hole yeah he stays right there
perfect so the good news is now i've
learned you can run
literally right in front of them as long
as you have a dung bomb out in the world
somewhere they will not care what you're
doing
they will not care however it only
distracts them for a very
very limited time before they're just
like nope
nope don't care about the dung bomb
anymore
heading straight for you now all right
i'd really like to go ahead and max out
let's see if we can get a fifth one here
nope
i think we were at four out of five
oh come on
is a dung bomb too much to ask for
a fifth dung bomb please yeah there we
go all right
so five out of five all right now we're
going to continue making our way toward
hagrid but also i want to stop at fred
and george's
and i want to see if there's anything
else i can buy at this point okay that
so that's still locked over there
and this one is going to lead to the
grand staircase all right nice
all right we're just gonna run straight
through run straight through
into the glanmore peaks corridor
and let's see i think it yeah it's this
one right here
okay all right fred george there you are
all right i want to see if somebody was
trolling me or if this is actually true
okay so you can buy dunk bombs with ron
nice
antidote to uncommon poisons
and dunk bomb case wait does that let me
store more i could carry more dun bombs
with this dung bomb case how much is it
100 100
of course they're trying to rip off
their brother that is ridiculous
a wig and weld potion
a rare collector's card
girding potion stink pellets okay
do i have enough for the for the rare
card
100 because they still want 100. all
right so now let's see what happens if i
switch to hermione
i mean still looks like the same stuff
oh no the little uh the bag disappeared
though
so you still got wigan weld you've still
got the rare card
still have the antidote
oh
dark forces a guide to self-protection
chapter one
i cannot believe this is actually a
thing
what wait what snuffle four's spell book
wow this snuffly for a spellbook will
allow me to turn things into mice
how much is it
50 30 watts every 50 50. okay we have
enough for that one
and then let's see how much this one is
how much is one of these chapters from
the dark forces a guide to
self-protection we thought you'd ask
about those
instead of beans
take this statue list what we'd like you
to do is fill it in by finding the nine
statues that it mentions around hogwarts
no way every three statues you find will
let you read one chapter of the dark
forces book to improve your ability to
cast spells a fair trade i think since
many of the statues are in places that
are often controlled by prefix oh of
course exactly
wait so what it makes the spells more
effective
oh my goodness dude i i can't believe i
didn't discover this before now
i can't believe it
folio brutai page let's see how much
that is what price is this page from the
folio brew tie one hundred bucks 100
oh get out of here
okay then the girding potion all right
so i definitely think we should buy the
one that we can afford here because i
mean that's probably gonna unlock
some special areas right
50 30 what's every flavor beans because
you can turn
something into mice got it the snuffly
force spell book
you're going to have a lot of fun with
the snuffly force spell hermione it's
particularly useful at turning books
turning books into mice
oh that's crazy
alright so looks like that is all the
spells that hermione can learn
i'm gonna go ahead and put that one on
x instead of flipindo transform small
books into mice so i wonder if it means
those flying books and let me go ahead
and see how many i think that's going to
take me down to a very small number
of birdy bop beans
uh 13. okay
hermione's statue list yeah let's see
what statues are on here bridgette
winlock gondolin oliphant
hingist of woodcroft
founder of hogsmeade glanmore peaks well
hey that's where we are that one should
be
fairly easy i would hope beaumont
margery banks gunhilda of gorsmore
gregory the smarmy jokunda sykes
hooky the house elf and then for every
what did they say three we find so let's
count them i think they're oh they're
nine total yeah hooky the house elf dude
this is awesome i hope hogwarts legacy
has something like this
oh i love that idea of like having these
special
statues that you have to go around the
castle and find
i can't believe i mean if i would have
known i could have been doing that long
before now
excuse me all right let's try
i think i might need ron for this right
what do you think of these things all
right let's see if ron can do anything
with it but actually before we do that
let's have him inspect
their bookshelf
you guys are gonna rip me off i might as
well look for more beans while i'm here
right
oh come on move it hurry move it
all right come on
more beans all right we'll take it even
though it's like
very slow going one bean at a time
all right so where are we at now exactly
wait haven't we been here already i feel
like we have
although that is still locked
and as far as i know hermione does not
have a
alohomora spell
let's see we've got that one we've got
the antidote connophores expelliarmus
rapero
yeah so she doesn't have that
interesting
all right well what we can do is
i think we can go back this way
i've probably already done this
i totally have most likely already done
this but i really i do not remember it
at all
only hermione'd fit through there all
right so let's hermione come on she can
go through
push the button
crawl back
oh nice it's like a bridge over here
all right perfect
okay so let's see what we got here
not gonna turn those into mice come on
all right so maybe we need
glaciers
okay she's probably gonna need to stay
standing on it
and then harry and ron can stand on the
other two as my guess
all right switch to them of course
they're just standing way back here
completely out of the way
all right harry let's do this one right
here
and ron
where are you boy there he is
okay
now what
okay there's a wizard card there how do
we get it
how do we get the wizard card
well we can all step off now
harry ca harry's the one who can climb
but it doesn't look like
even he cannot climb this apparently
all right well maybe a spell
it's still making a sound though
okay and we can lock on to it with a
spell too
or with our
lock-on ability there
and yet nothing happens
okay let's look at harry spells again
carpe retract them that one could be a
possibility expelliarmus expect a
patronum
oh come on
there we go
nice
i was thinking this should work
let's see if it actually goes through
and of course i have not checked my
wizard cards in a while so i'm gonna
have no idea
no idea which new one this is but
oh wait not that book uh
this book right here
uh five out of five on the witches
morgan le fay
look at that one right there i'm pretty
sure i've had that one queen maeve
pretty sure i've had that one
ignacia wildsmith beatrix bloxham gun
hilda of course more so that's the
that's one of the statues we need to
find right there
okay and so we have three wizards merlin
medieval dates unknown we also have
glanmore peaks that's another statue we
need to find
edgar schrolder
and
vampires i'm pretty sure this is uh yeah
sir herbert varney
we already found him that is not a new
one
goblins we've got two goblins
algaf the awful foul smelling goblin
nuisance well known throughout the
goblin world for trying to sell vials of
his sweat to a dung bomb manufacturer
and this ear get the ugly her eerigit
uh goblin representative at 14th century
summit of wizards council
and then oh man dragons that's gonna be
pretty cool two giants so far
goliath i think yep i've read that one
before
and then more halt
ancient celtic dates a known gigantic
brother of the king of ireland wounded
tristan the celtic hero with a poisoned
sword when the ladder tried to kill him
yeah it's been so long i i can't
remember which of these are new and
which of these uh aren't new
classical beasts the giant squid the
unicorn the mountain troll
giant squid i feel like i've seen that
before too so well one of those is new
uh we just picked up one of them all the
quidditch ones i've had those for a
while
those were the first five that i
gathered i'm pretty sure
all right so let's close this this was a
detour uh that was well worth our time
finding the other wizard card uh the
only thing is it doesn't seem like we
yet have a way
to get behind this see what happens if
you
yeah nothing
all right well back through fred and
george's we'll go
all right this way
come on come on move out of the way fred
or george not really sure
not really sure which one of you that is
all right and now we can go on glamor
peaks corridor we should be able to find
the statue here if it's not hidden
too much
and actually i want to switch to ron too
oh wait wait hermione with your new
spell does it work on these
yes
so is that like the only use case for it
i wonder
i'm trying to think oh wait
why did we get a book for this great i
mean a
a wizard card let's go
unless the maybe the mice like run in
here
they ran in there and that triggered a
wizard card
that's the only thing i can think of
all right so now hopefully we should be
able to remember which one is
new here
okay we definitely had five there we
definitely had three there we definitely
only had two goblins we had one of those
we had two
giants
i have no idea
maybe it must have been the hags
baba yaga medieval dates unknown
pretty sure i've had that one maladora
grim medieval dates unknown
used a beautification potion to conceal
her true hack form married a true king
used a charmed mirror to reinforce her
self-image became jealous of the most
beautiful girl in the land and fed her a
poison apple ah i know that story old
mother hubbard i think this is a new one
medieval dates unknown lured straight
animals into her home and starved them
to death oh my goodness
goodness gracious
insanity all right and this hags of
course is the one category i don't
believe we clicked on at all last time
so
uh not sure which one of those is new
maybe maybe two two of the new ones came
from that category most likely but we
still have no dragons we need two more
classical beasts three more goblins four
more vampires and then two more
regular wizards
all right so let's go ahead and back out
of here and we just need to make sure
whenever we see those that we uh quickly
switch to hermione
but while i'm here i'm gonna go ahead
and switch to ron search these i mean
does it really only give you one bean oh
my goodness that just doesn't seem worth
it like just the the animation
it just takes too long for only one bean
that should be at least three beans for
that animation right there
but instead you have to go to each
individual one
and you know what i'm actually going to
switch to hermione so i'll have that
wait this looks like the uh
i don't quite know what to think about
the escape of that serious black
character
what he did to the fat lady
was
indescribable
i just hope that if he does intend to
continue his campaign against works of
art that he does it far away from here
far away from here we really should be
going yeah he looks like one of the
statues
can i talk to this portrait too
no okay all right so where does this one
lead this one leads to east wing
and this actually where's wrong
yeah yeah he'll be fine ron he'll be
fine this almost looks like a secret
passage right here
yep exactly what i was thinking
let's go ahead and open that up here
great another wizard card
all right now
we should definitely be able to remember
who the new one is here
all right let's go in
and
giants we only had two giants before and
that one is the new one right there bran
the bloodthirsty medieval dates unknown
lived in a castle on top of an enchanted
beanstalk hey
apparently fond of eating bread made
with ground bones and washed down with
the blood of an englishman was slain by
a boy named jack
very cool
i like how it ties into
to our own uh stories that aren't just
you know made up in the world of harry
potter
we should be going
yeah you're right hermione i actually
agree with you all for once i agree with
you all we should be going let's go
ahead and go through here proceed out to
the sixth floor corridor and i think
we're in wait is this the statue right
here
yes
okay so what happens now does it
automatically check that off
because let's see hermione's the one who
had the
the book
right
here hermione statue list
yes there it is all right that's awesome
okay
so that's one of them that was easy to
knock out and while we're here there are
also some books
that we can turn into mice
there we go oh and it totally does give
you stuff
whenever there's a uh one of these
little holes nearby i guess the mice
automatically go in
and then you get something in return i
like that all right so we need to be on
the lookout for statues we need to be on
the lookout for the aries with uh mice
or with the books
which we can then turn into mice
this is why all right ancient runes
fifth floor muggle studies i'm just
gonna start looking for statues
everywhere
oh yeah this is the room where we get
into the big fight with uh
malfoy and all of them
oh i love how this
the smuggle studies classroom area is
all right come on harry
can ron fit through
oh that's funny
come on now it's not like
hermione's that much smaller than them
all right so
let's see harry pick up
come on
all right now switch to ron
you pick up i don't know if i've done
this already or not
i mean you have to be lined up just
right okay we definitely have it nice
dude we are racking up on the
collectibles and wizard cards this
episode for sure
finding lots of things that we haven't
before bertie bought beans let's go now
that's what i'm talking about right
there
a stack like that
that should be what comes out of the
bookshelves as well when you use ron all
right we still got more to find here
whoa more muggle studies
oh dude this is so cool but what is that
up here okay that's the one of the
draconophores
all right so let's go into here switch
spells
wait what oh i bet i have to get up
there
it's such a slow moving spell
okay what keep out to the y
excuse me
keep out of the way what is happening
dude i'm lost flapindo maybe
why am i getting attacked by rubber
ducks
is this a mr weasley
connection here a little easter egg for
mr weasley
tell me
what exactly is the function of a rubber
duck
come on
oh dude hermione's like almost out
we're gonna need a potion
oh come on get away from him get away
oh she's gone she's gone i can't even
get ron's help
i can't even get ron and harry in here
okay do we have any potions we can use
with her
yes we do we can weld replenish his
stamina all right we're gonna need it
quickly
use it fast use it fast
dude they're following me out here too
oh my goodness
these rubber ducks they're insane
okay that spell doesn't seem to be
having any effect whatsoever on them
i think vopindo was working it was just
i was kind of overwhelmed there was a
lot of them in there all right so maybe
we can isolate this one for a bit
all right so flipino definitely works
took that one out right there
all right let's put some distance here
the only two left it's not bad we got
this
we got this just had to get away for a
little bit
all right and then i think oh suddenly
there's two more
okay
are we clear i think we're clear for now
okay so hermione can hop up on these i
feel like the arrows are definitely a
hint
over and up okay
see grab
okay but that's still not enough for her
to
what about this side
nice all right
oh and then we can repair this
i really do love how they used lots of
different spells and they required you
to kind of switch between lots of
different spells the only bad part is
that it's just so annoying to actually
have to switch
that's the most annoying part
all right so now we're probably gonna
need to
let's see hold on hold on hold on
hermione don't just push it off here
i feel like we might need to stack it
yeah we definitely are going to need
this one to stack
on top of the other one
i think anyway
okay now let me check the alignment here
uh not quite i think we need to pull it
back just a bit
right there nope like right there right
there let go let go
and let's see
nice okay drop down
watch it be too heavy now
oh it's gonna be so mad oh no wait
okay let go
now this one
nope don't hop up on there just yet i
want you to grab it oh can i not pull
this one back there we go
that's exactly where we want it right
there
and now we're just going to push this
one all the way
all right hopefully that will be enough
for her to jump up
nice all right let's go
okay cast the
wrong spell
back into our menu again here we go
i love the little whispers when you
select the spell somebody was talking
about that last time in the comments i
completely agree
are you serious you have to be that
close for this thing
there we go
it's just such a nice little touch when
you hear that whisper
okay you're gonna stop there we go all
right make sure there's nothing else in
this room at least there i don't think
there's anything else i can get to at
the moment
oh my goodness where are we hermione
okay i do not like running into the
camera like that when we have no idea
which way we're going
nice another collectible
more beans wizard card more beans all
right
i mean honestly like when it's that many
beans i'm not going to complain
because we definitely need to get a
hundred of them
okay i feel like we're gonna need to
cast a spell on that eye right there
oh wait we've been in this room before
this is where you fight that uh
is he down there
the red cap i'm pretty sure you find a
red cap in here
all right so i feel like the rest of the
room is sealed off though right
because we can't
can't jump up there with hermione
nowhere to jump up here there are no
items for me to
um bring over anything unless you can
like somehow target that plane
i think we're good here i think we're
good for that room
now i do want to double check in this
room just to make sure yeah go ahead and
drop down
i just want to make sure that there's
not a way if i did bring those
blocks over here i
wonder
i wonder if you could get up there i
mean how else would you get in that room
right
we're gonna try it
we shall see what happens
all right let go spin it around
oh is there not enough room
yeah there's enough room there's enough
room
all right let go of that and then we're
just gonna need to
pull this one
all the way down
go ahead and let go right now hermione
come on there you go
all right push it this way
this one i have a feeling we won't be
able to get on because of the
oh it was worth a shot
it was worth a shot
okay nothing else over there
see if i push them anywhere else okay we
could get on top of there that's not
gonna do anything we already were up
there
and all of this is blocked off with the
the railing up top
anything we can interact with here does
not look like it i mean the only thing i
can think of would be if you could grab
on to that right there
but i don't think so i think that's too
high
all right let's head back here
harry and ron still
still holding it for us
all right
good job guys thank you
okay yeah i mean this has been a really
good
really good episode for us going around
and gathering a few more collectibles
we do still need to find
several more statues as well
but for now
i'm just gonna continue our little
exploration here
oh and look there we go another chest
oh but this one's locked
we need aloha mora for this one
okay let's see just a flapindo maybe on
this
is it playing now
okay nothing yeah i definitely remember
this room
oh and now we're back here in the bottom
of this room
oh and there he is i knew i heard him
somewhere
i was like where am i hearing that guy
from
all right there he is and i don't see
let's just double check and make sure
there's not one of those statues in here
let's see can we climb up there harry
nope guess not
and i don't see any of the statues
all right back in the grand staircase
let's see we've got fourth floor history
of magic
all right so we need to be on the
lookout for oh wait wait i heard it i
heard it
where are they hermione where are they
where are the books
there they are
come on out
relax ron
wait are there more that we have to
because there's definitely oh right
there dude that one was very well hidden
got lucky right there finding that one
you have completed the hacks card set
hermione's endurance has increased let's
go
all right let's go and take a look and
see who the final hag is
in the
folio universitas
okay we got hags here
cordelia
misera cordia
hag representative at the 14th century
summit of wizards council
oh well that was kind of boring right
after the other ones these were all kind
of uh
crazy latisha somnolens i don't remember
that one
yeah i think that one might be new too
and then we unlocked the big one as a
result so
this spiteful hag was jealous of the
king's daughter and caused her to prick
her finger on a spindle tainted with a
draught of the living death
a young wizard who had smeared his lips
with wigan well potion kissed the
princess and brought her out of her
trance
nice another recognizable story there
for many of us
all right let's go ahead and return here
oh see look another spot for the mice
right here
and where are the books i hear them i
hear them
come on come on hermione
that's it
there we go
now
all right so got more beans right there
all right now have we done this one
right here yet
secret way to the second floor
is there a hidden statue back here
oh there is let's go which statue is
this bundling
to my list gondoline ollyphone they're
going to execute
ron relax dude okay so we have already
found this one though look that's proof
that we've been here before
all right so i'm gonna go ahead and pop
out on the second floor
because i believe one of the statues
is right there in the main
uh like the main area at the bottom
floor
i think
i think i'm not 100
but all right while we're here we might
as well all right come on books attack
us
come on hermione why can you not target
all right there we go
all right couple more beans there hey
i'll take it
it's not a wizard card but i'll take it
oh yeah i should be switching to ron a
little bit too to have him
search these for us as we go even though
it's just for beans
that kind of looks like a hidden passage
but
no luck there on that one
all right so we've definitely already
done this one too
can we go now but still might lead to a
place that we
haven't unlocked yet in terms of a
statue
oh okay we got that guy staring right at
us not good
okay i'm just kind of glancing around
the room to see if there are any statues
over in that area we got prefects right
there which means there probably is a
statue here somewhere on this floor
because they said fred and george said
it would be in areas where there are
lots of prefix or at least some of them
would be
okay i think we have to wait for him to
yeah do that right there
oh come on the camera i still cannot
believe it is a horizontal inverted
camera
it just it boggles my mind
every time i hop on to play this
okay
i'm just using this to walk hopefully
quietly
all right are there any statues right
here
oh there is this
is this i feel like we should at least
double check this spot right here secret
passageway okay well might be something
might be something worthwhile
oh i heard it you heard it too
come on get that other one
oh come on there he is get it get it get
it
all right now hurry up
here it is over here more potions
okay that definitely looks like
oh that's one that you find
from up top and then you
slide down
okay nothing that way
all right let's go ahead and proceed
second floor corridor
wait this is just where we were right
yeah it's literally right where we were
well maybe there's a statue on the other
side
all right honestly though i'm kind of
ready
to go for buck beak here
kind of ready to go on and see what
happens
wait why do i keep hearing something
back here
it sounded like feet shuffling
what is this one again
we really should be going
i cannot remember what that one is
hopefully i've already activated it
because i do not remember
all right i will on my way out double
check and see if that statue i was
thinking about
is here i feel like it was this way
wait what that's completely sealed off
okay that's just
strange come on let's go
maybe it's down here then
yes there we go okay
oh wait do i have to be i probably have
to be on hermione
that's jackender
that's three entries on my list
fred and george are bound to let me read
one of the chapters from the dark forces
book
yep they are indeed
but i'm gonna see
if we can't find one more
i mean this seems like a very logical
place to have one but it looks like
looks like it's just dueling right now
and
yeah i'm not seeing one all right so
hagrid's we go let us find out the fate
of buckbeak
and while we're on our way we'll be on
the lookout for any statues i feel like
it said there was one in the courtyard
but that might have been the missing
the missing item
there it is
it's the parcel
parcel that the al dropped returned the
outpost board for more house points
perfect all right so we found that
that's another thing to check off our
list
now let's go ahead and head down to
hagrid's
i'm curious to know how much of the game
is left because
i mean this scene in the book this is
kind of when you're reading the book
this is when you hit the point of no
return there's still quite a bit left
but once you read this it's just like oh
you got to go all in at that point you
just you really want to know what's
what's going to happen there
all right hold on am i going the wrong
way i say this every time
i'm always like wait a second where's
hagrids again and then i find it
just behind the trees over here
all right do we have the invisibility
cloak hagrid
or harry
do we go around back here
come on let's go see hagrid
oh i guess we're supposed to go in the
house
as harry ron and hermione arrived at
hagrid's hut the executioner came to
seal buckbeak's fate mcnair he's here
don't let him see you
pretty sure his name was mcnair
how could they
scabbers it's okay
and here we go
i think the dogs appeared at all in the
game
i do not remember the dog appearing in
the game at all and yes i know who the
dog is but just for those who are
trying to experience this in real time
we don't yet know
the identity of the dog you guys so
not gonna spoil it here and we are
officially we are inside the whomping
willow at this point
what
okay wait that's gonna be a carpe
retractum right
hey you
there you go hermione
get him out of there
another shield here
oh
goodness
the frames
the frames
[Music]
okay we definitely need more carpet
retract them because more of them have
these little shields too
ouch
dude they are just all over us man
back off
come on harry you got this
get out of the way
oh did i get him
there we go
yeah we're definitely gonna need that
that potion
still doing okay on health surprisingly
even though i feel like we've really
taken a lot of hits for sure
there you go i'll slide out of the way
hermione nice
all right we got one left and got him
okay
all right let's continue making our way
here see if we can find ron
oh great
hermione what are you doing
she just walks right up there
okay
gotta switch to glaciers
yes
all right we got it
come on harry
no i'm not in the way trying to get the
other one for you the one that's still
on fire harry
there we go
all right harry finish him off
nicely done nicely done
okay oh now we're gonna need harry for a
pay retract them like see i love this i
love that they had
as we move closer and closer toward the
end game they're really making sure you
utilize all the spells
i think that's great
can we make that jump
can we make it
oh yes nice job harry
all right before we can take those guys
out though we're gonna need hermione
over here
because she's the only one who knows
glaciers i'm i'm not a fan of that like
that certain characters know are the
only ones that know the spells
i like it for the gameplay scenarios
though like i do like that that they
encourage you to
need to use all three of the characters
but
i really wish it wasn't locked out wait
why did it just oh did she completely
she completely fainted not good
can i give her a wigging weld
oh that one's going to go back and get
on fire again isn't
he oh come on right there you
why is it not locking on to him okay
thank you
i think i just have to wait it out don't
i
or is there a way to give her a potion
let's see
yeah i won't let me switch to her
all right let's equip that though
i'm just gonna walk right up here oh
there she is
okay come on hermione
this way
all right now let's switch to you
and then let's
hopefully she has one yeah
she does indeed have one all right let's
go ahead and use the wig and weld
[Music]
nice and you know what just so i don't
have to switch back to harry i mean even
though he is trying to take them out for
me
after i freeze them i'm gonna go ahead
and
put flopindo on for her as well
all right that's one
that's two
i feel like there are more now they're
multiplying
oh yeah they keep coming out what the
heck
here we go all right that's frozen so
hopefully they're not gonna be anymore
now
harry get up here dude
help a girl out come on
oh there we go
[Music]
nice all right
i think we got them all
all right let's go harry ready to
proceed
hermione doing all the hard work as
usual
as usual
and this this goes down deep here oh now
we got these things
i'm in the way are you serious
doxie bites are poor isness oh joy
oh joy the poisonous doxie bites you
guys
[Music]
we know what hermione fortunately we do
actually have some antidote and i think
it said harry is poison too
all right so let's go ahead and use the
antidote on hermione i need some
antidote
harry needs the antidote as well
all right harry
oh no come on back to harry antidote
i need some antidotes i'm giving you're
literally drinking it man
calm down gonna even i'm even gonna use
wiggin weld for you buddy
even gonna use wigan welds so you are
fully back up to speed so is hermione
unfortunately though harry has no spells
equipped so we're gonna go ahead and
throw on carpe retract them actually you
know what i bet we're going to need
expelliarmus soon
it's just a guess i bet we're going to
need it soon because i feel like we're
having to use all our skills here
in this final uh
see me it seems like a final area wait
what are you shooting at hermione
what are you what are you
oh they're over there again
all right so i guess we have to drop
down
definitely going to need hermione for
repairo
all right let's go into the
right raparo
probably should have used wigan weld for
her as well
come on drop down you got it
okay i was about to say are they in here
now
oh wait can i not repair
this whoa whoa whoa what is going on
dude they are going crazy up there
okay let's see can harry jump up there
no he can't
all right maybe we have to carpe retract
them
and pull them down here
having trouble getting one connect here
yeah they're just like showing their
they run up they show their face and
then back off
okay what am i missing here guys
what am i missing all right it looks
like he cannot
jump up there's nothing he can do to
grab on oh and we can't even go back now
so we're totally locked in here
i mean this really feels like one of the
repair ones
[Music]
come on can you move the camera around
yeah i know that
dude it would not let me lock on that is
so sneaky right there
it would not let me lock onto that box
which is i mean that's exactly what i
tried to do from the beginning
let me lock on i just had to aim the
spell in that sort of general direction
and it it fortunately worked
all right i'm immediately going to try
and press this
nope looks like we can't
alright let's switch let go let's get
hermione up there
and she's gonna need flopindo very
quickly as well
dude water distracted by harry
nice hermione just took all of them out
let's go
all right so do we need a
oh we might need to stand on this block
over here to actually
this one is so large it's gonna take
both of us
oh they do that so you
they basically want to ensure that
there's no way possible
for you to hit this while the uh red
caps are still up here because look how
smoke slow you have to move for that all
right let's climb up harry and push the
button
and there we go now we can proceed still
making our way
through the depths of the whomping
willow a tunnel from the whomping willow
headed to the shrieking shack
harry discovered that the black dog was
in fact serious
trying to know
dude that was like a very condensed
version of it but okay
it works
[Music]
man this this was just so awesome in the
book
my jaw was just on the floor
you just get so many shocks like back to
back to back
i wonder if they're gonna have snape
show up in the in the game
oh dude we're already here we are here
they are skipping we are at the patronus
oh my goodness ladies and gentlemen it
is time the final battle
harry versus the dementors
wait hermione what are you what are you
doing hermione
where are you going
what what is this
where am i supposed to take him
i have no idea what i'm supposed to be
doing oh wiggle repeatedly to break free
[Music]
man the sound effects are actually
really awesome
and by awesome i mean terrifying
like am i supposed to drop him and cast
hold on hold on hold on
because i don't have any spells equipped
why is it not
okay you can't right now this is what
i'm supposed to be doing all right just
making sure
because it feels like it's like okay am
i supposed to stop and cast expect a
patronum or am i supposed to keep
dragging him it seems like i'm supposed
to keep dragging him for now so that's
what we're gonna do come on come on come
on
problem is we are quickly losing health
too
and unfortunately hermione does not know
expected patronum
which at this point was a a cannon thing
in the books as well
harry learned it very early it was like
one of the few things he had
on hermione
at least in terms of learning it before
her of course she would eventually go on
to learn it
with harry's help by the way but right
now she would be of no help to us
a rarity
a very rare scenario for hermione to
find herself in okay we made it all
right dude that is a bunch of dementors
that is a bunch of oh wait here we go
it's time steer them away
away from him
oh come on where's the stag
where's the sag dude
[Music]
oh
okay
the patronus is a little hard to drive
it's a little difficult to pilot the
patronus
oh wow that was bad
we just just hit one of them i don't
care which one
[Music]
dude how is that not hitting him
okay definitely hit that one
there we go just barely had to
shift it just a little bit over to the
left okay we got that one too
oh he's dead dude he's gone we lost
wait did we save him
his health looks completely drained oh
yeah we lost
i was thinking his health looked
completely drained are you serious i
have to drag him all the way back again
though
no way
all right here we go harry
let's try this again
expecto patronum can we drive the
patronus a little bit better this time
oh there we go
that one should just go straight ahead
okay just
now this one's
getting a little bit closer dude why is
his health still going down
there are no dementors whatsoever close
to him
i don't see any kind of like health bar
for the dementors either so i wonder if
this is a timing thing if we just have
to
keep them at bay for so long
or drive them back to a certain distance
okay we got this one on the right who's
kind of inching up a little bit closer
i mean we're doing much better this time
for sure
even if we go on to lose this one right
now
doing a much better job at keeping them
at bay here
that one's getting a little bit closer
right
there we go there we go triggered the
cutscene
yes there's the stag let's go
dad
now captured sirius black awaited his
fate on the seventh floor of the west
tower harry and hermione awoke in the
hospital ring eager to explode
black's telling the truth he's innocent
professor i believe everything you say
but there is nothing i can do
what we need
is more
time hermione understood immediately
dumbledore was giving them permission to
use the time turner she'd been using all
year to attend several lessons at once
we're going to use the time turner to go
back three hours rescue buck beak and
then save sirius having rescued buckbeak
harry and hermione hid amongst the
bushes beside the lake okay so skipped
ahead a little bit there
by the dementors harry's mind wrestled
with the vision of the shadowy figure
and the ghostly creature that he had
seen by the lakeside
i know it sounds crazy
but i think it was my dad
harry you mustn't be seen
it was time for the rescuer to appear
but no one was coming to help this time
and then it was
such an epic moment
he had seen himself
i've got to save
them them you mean us right
[Music]
let's go dude
expecto
patronum
charge wait what does that mean
oh this is cool we're the stag now
[Applause]
i have no idea if i'm doing what i'm
supposed to be doing
okay we're charging it up
okay that that time i held y down a
little bit longer i feel like it lasted
longer
yeah i don't feel like we're saving him
guys
i'm supposed to like tap a or hold a
no
his life force is draining
[Music]
okay that time i didn't push a at all
and i feel like it lasted longer
okay now i'm holding a
yeah when you hold a it just immediately
goes
[Music]
the dementors like wait hold on there
their life is not draining at all this
is not good
maybe i need to get to sirius
oh there we go i was there dude i was
there okay we've kind of cleared a path
now
unfortunately he's about dead
okay yeah charge charge charge charge
come on
come on
there we go
okay that was it we took down one of
their health bars
unfortunately we cannot let another one
even come close to touching him
so that's what we're supposed to do
we're supposed to clear a path
basically to where we could get through
and tackle the ones that are like right
there beside him
and then you just charge directly into
them
all right so a little bit past the
halfway marker on
the dementor health bar
no no no no come on get through there
yes
nice nice nice
charge it up charge it up charge it up
there you go
where is it there he is
no
no
i am right there
yes let's go
oh man we figured that one out at the
last possible second
literally one more hit sirius was gone
dude had to repeat all that
serious i know but they'll soon be
coming to take him to the tower we've
got to hide do you reckon sirius is up
there yet
who's that coming out of the castle
mcnair the executioner ah was right
what's new mentors
one of us has got to get buckbeat to
that tower
what are you doing
get to the tower what are you doing okay
fine
do i really need to bow buckbeak oh my
gosh you totally do
you totally have to bow okay fine all
right let's go lucky we gotta move we
gotta move
oh nope not pause that's not what i want
to do
and hold to fly
all right dementors are coming
we know he's going to be
he's on top of a tower somewhere
which tower is the question
right there that looks like an ideal
spot
yeah there we go how can i ever think
get on there's not much time
here he's like stop
go
we'll see each other again
you truly are your father's son harry
[Music]
[Music]
behind what had happened the night that
sirius buck beacon pettigrew had
vanished except harry hermione professor
dumbledore and ron
i trust that you will make the best of
the last day of time wait last week
for another year
and
yes
i was wondering how they were going to
handle this like could i still roam and
do stuff
i'll remind you that we will soon hold
the house cup ceremony
but if you would like to run along now
oh that's awesome when you're ready to
see who's won
that's a great way of handling it in
this game i love that so it's basically
like all right here's dumbledore he's
ready to trigger the in-game whenever
you're ready
but you're free to roam and explore the
castle if you want finish up on all
those side quests finish up on anything
else that you want to take care of first
i think that is a perfect way to handle
it and i also think that is going to be
the perfect spot for us to end this
video guys if you enjoyed this give it a
thumbs up it's going to help more people
find these let's pay videos as always
thank you all so much for watching
and i will talk to you again soon